>> Rishi Chandra: Let's look at a few examples.
First, I would like to invite Hunter Walk
from YouTube to showcase an exciting new YouTube
site.
Hunter.
[ Applause ]
>>Hunter Walk: Thanks.
So we couldn't be more excited about Google
TV. We really think this is the platform that
starts to bring the interactivity of the Web
into the living room.
And so we're proud to announce the development
of YouTube lean-back which is meant to take
the entire YouTube corpus, hundreds of millions
of videos, and turn them into an experience
that you can lean back and enjoy.
The first thing you notice is that when you
go to YouTube Lean-Back it just starts playing.
There's no browsing, no searching, no clicking.
It behaves like you would expect television
to. And what is it playing? Well, it's playing
one very important channel, the channel of
you.
A personalized video feed that's meant to
be exactly the content that you want to watch.
For example, this first video was favorited
by my friend Simon. He was on YouTube, he
saw it, he liked it, he favorited it. Because
we are friends, it gets pushed into my stream.
So using Google TV we are able to make the
living room social.
But you don't have to just rely on your friends.
There is also lots of great content in your
personal feed based upon what we think you
are going to like. So for example, here is
a music video from one of my favorite artists.
Now, why is this here? It's because I subscribed
to his channel on YouTube which means as he
uploads new content, I am going to get it
right away. We have essentially turned all
your preferences into video subscriptions
that are just waiting for you.
But we don't have to rely just on the channel
of you. Beyond that, there's other ways you
can browse. There are a bunch of default channels
of things you would expect, comedy, music,
news and sports, and you can even add your
own channels, like a channel dedicated unicorns,
if that's what you are into. I like sports;
manly, manly sports.
And of course, as YouTube adds new content,
it's going to show up here as well.
So my rentals. As you might have heard, we
started to roll out paper stream abilities
for content creators on our platform. What
happens is you rent that on YouTube.com and
it's waiting right here on your television
for you to bring up and watch. So it's just
that simple.
So in all, we really believe that, prior,
lean-back meant you had to give up control.
You had to watch what somebody else programmed
for you. But with YouTube lean-back on Google
TV, you are going to be able to access your
personal video feed in beautiful HD on your
TV at any time you want. And because developing
for Google TV is just like developing for
the Web, this isn't a TV device. This is a
Web interface. And so within the next few
weeks, I am happy to announce we are going
to be launching a beta of this on the YouTube
Web site that you can access, try out for
yourself and give us feedback. So we are incredibly
excited by Google TV and YouTube lean-back.
Thanks.